My piece is to be able to answer the question in regards to the role of the care partner
in optimizing patient outcomes for multiple myeloma.
And what you see on this slide, it just highlights, again, my personal story in the fact that
from a J&J perspective, as far as my husband being diagnosed with multiple myeloma and
really being able to go through, again, the unknown about multiple myeloma, educating
myself, educating us, talking countless times with specialists in order to be able to understand
what this disease is, because we were blindsided, and then being able, from a diagnostic perspective,
to really understand the diagnosis and then being able to make that decision for treatment,
which we had to do quite quickly, and then, of course, being able to live now with the
impact of multiple myeloma.
So that put me into an advocate.
So I'm sharing with you here the slide that just highlights, again, it's just a snapshot.
I'm not going to go into details in regards to the overall care pattern, but just to have
you see here, snapshotly, we work quite aggressively in taking care of my husband and being able
to navigate through nine different lines of treatment, all trying to find the best care
for him, the best treatment plan that will be able to put his disease at least in the
right place and to remission.
I will want to acknowledge that this is 2020 into 2023, and it warms my heart to see the
medical advancement that has been able to take place.
Once we started, we started with a triple induction therapy, and today, because of you
in this room, because of all of the research that you have done, we're now looking at quad
and being able to more aggressively go after that frontline treatment.
Another great thing.
Another great medical advancement is, you know, CAR-T.
For us, CAR-T was our fourth line treatment.
Today, that has transitioned up to a second line treatment.
So all moving in the right direction, just based on the research of everyone in this
room.
So I do thank you.
However, within the process, and we fight quite courageously in order to get the best
care, one of the things that I want to highlight as far as our challenge, we had access.
Access was not an issue.
But as I mentioned, we had access.
I mentioned the late diagnosis and not having the value of having that pre-screening.
When we got to, I'm based in Chicago, we're based in Chicago, and we were at a major cancer
center being able to seek care.
But based on my connections, I was able to find out very late in the stage about an expanded
clinical trial, and that was taking place at Cleveland Clinic with Dr. Mazzanio.
That's how I got connected from Chicago all the way to Cleveland.
And that, even for me today, having that access, having that privilege to participate
into an expanded study that was not available in my area, brings me a great deal of peace
right now in knowing, again, we sought the best care.
But this is not the case for everyone.
Folks are not able to travel even four miles, not four miles, four hours away to seek care.
They're not able to get state to state to seek care.
And this is what remains a burden on my heart.
In order to, one, ensuring that there is access for others to be able to get treatment.
So I really encouraged by the discussion as far as the community, being able to look at
the community approach and being able to bridge that gap to being sure that we're having care.
But also, I want you to think about across the line, across the state, that there may
not be a certain clinical trial in your area.
And really being able to consider the patient and trying to save that one patient life to
be able to partner with another institution that may be in another state and then at least
make that as an option.
So that was definitely a key learning that I do want to highlight.
The second part is the opportunity, again, of data representation.
Unfortunately for us, with some of the drugs that we tried, there was not significant data
that was represented that was able to really identify demographically what and how others,
you know, I'm going to say, you know, you're going to be able to do that.
I'm going to say within the high-risk community responded to these treatment.
So these were very difficult decisions that we had to make in order to, one, be able to,
you know, seek care and be able to indulge in some of these trials.
So I do encourage you as you're doing your research, please be able to identify and really
think about all patients in mind and be able to document the different patients that are
able to be able to go through from a demographic perspective.
To provide that opportunity.
For us, again, I remain at peace.
I remain grateful to Dr.
Mazanio because she established with us a trust, a trust that was there that I'm going to say at
the end of life, she was fighting for us.
And, you know, having that trust is quite important.
So spending that time with patients was quite significant to us.
She understood, you know, us personally, understood what we were getting to.
And as I talk,
with more and more patients, there is not always that opportunity for trust,
for building relationship with their oncology team,
which really makes a difference in the overall care notion.
So as I close out us here today as to, you know, from a care partner perspective,
being able to, you know, get optimal care, optimal outcome for patients.
And of course, in this case, your loved ones, you know, really, again,
being that.
The patient is the voice for the voiceless.
I always like to say the patient is the, the heart and the soul as to how we enable purpose driven
mission to move forward, how we enable practice to move forward, but also including that care
partner, because the care partner is the engine, right behind the scenes that are making the
calls, managing through this, navigating this disease to ensure that the patient is focused on,
you know, one most important assignment, living and living through this.
disease. So again, I do want to thank you for this opportunity.